Hi guys, it's me, Erik! And I am coming to
you live... uh, live? I don't know if it's live.
I'm coming to you live, sort of, from a
vacation destination that has too much
sunlight. The reason I'm making this
though is that there are a lot of
exciting things happening at new rockstars, and me and the team felt like it
was time to fill you in. In fact, you
might have seen our channel banner
teasing this all month long. So the
purpose of this video is to share with
you some really important updates. But
also, and I'm really excited about this,
it's to get some ideas from you, all
about where we should take some of these
things. Stick around to the end of this
video to find out how you can share some
of your ideas with us, but up first, one
of our big announcements. We've been
trying really hard to make this happen,
and I'm really excited to tell you that
Filup Molina is coming back! Fimo
himself! WHAAAAAT??
That's so stupid. You might know him as the guy
with the hat. Or who knows? You might not
know him at all. But don't worry, it's not
like I'm going anywhere, and Filup is
really great, actually it was him who quasi-founded this version of new rockstars
and started this whole business of
breakdowns that we know and love. But
Filup's not the only person being added
to the team, and those aren't the only
announcements, but I'll let Filup
explain, and I'll be back in the indoors
where I belong very soon. But for now,
take it away, Filup!  Hey guys, I'm Filup Molina.
It has been a while. Look at my name down
there! Yes I know, it is spelled awful, who
cares? I am back! It's a nondenominational
holiday miracle! We did it! Okay,
I'm gonna be totally genuine - before I
say anything else, I absolutely have to
thank these complete badasses who have
been taking care of this channel, Erik
and Ericson. It honestly... it just means
so much to me, like I feel like I owe you
guys everything. Guys, this channel felt
like my baby. Like, albeit yes, a baby that
I accidentally sort of left on the bus
and I could be charged with all sorts of
neglect for, but don't worry about that
now. Look at what you've grown! You're so
big! There's almost a million of you, that's
amazing. I remember when we used to shoot this
thing in my apartment and my dog Kylo
edited for free. Now, in the interest of
full disclosure, I have to admit I never
totally left new rockstars. I mean, how
could I? It was literally still shot in
my apartment
until pretty recently, but now that I am
fully back, all the way in,
maximum effort, I am just so incredibly
happy. Like, you have no idea how much I missed
you guys.
Seriously, you there, you. I have been out
in the real world. It's not awesome. But
you guys, the audience, you are the most
intelligent, kind audience on YouTube.
Getting to talk about nerdy stuff with
you all is an absolute privilege, and
coming back here was a complete
no-brainer because of you, so thank you.
But enough emotions, they clash with my
programming. Back to announcements!
Lately new rockstars has been getting provided
with a bunch of opportunities that are
completely game-changing. Like, over the
years, it always tore me and Erik up
when we would get tweets from you all
asking us to give our opinion on
something cool, or like, an awesome nerdy
thing would happen and then we just
would not have the bandwidth to talk
about it, or by the time we could, that
thing was long gone. But now the channel
is really getting to a place where the
gross, acne phase of its puberty is like,
almost done. Either way, it's coming really
close to the oh-so-exciting growth spurt
that's been awaiting. This has been gross.
You guys might have noticed that in the
past couple of weeks we've been
experimenting with more videos, and
really we're just trying to get ready
for a situation where we can start doing
more and more content. Like, the eventual
goal is to make stuff for you all daily.
That is so huge for us.
We used to struggle to get one video up
per week, if that. But also, one thing
I've learned is that growing pains suck
when you go through them alone. So get
ready, because I want you to go through
them with us. I've seen other channels
really struggle through periods of
growth, and I feel like that's been
because of two reasons: one, they stop
doing the stuff that everyone loved
about the channel in order to start
doing the new stuff, and two, they didn't
ask the audience what new stuff they
wanted. So here's my pledge to you: the
breakdown and analysis videos are not
going away and there's not going to be
less of them, either. They can't go away,
they are literally how my brain works.
But the new content - I want you to help
us come up with it. And here's the thing,
I said it earlier, you're the smartest
audience I've ever encountered,
so I'm going to give you some real
transparency here: Yes, we're growing and
yes, the ideal content to add would be even more
breakdowns and analysis videos. They're
addictive as hell and we love making
them, but we can't. lLike, at least not
without having breakdowns ourselves. The
research, the writing, the editing... No lie,
I seriously worked 100 hours a week, I'm
not kidding,
when I was trying to get those breakdown
videos out, and I'd get maybe one out. So
again, I'm going to reiterate, we're not
replacing the breakdowns, we're not
looking to do less of them, but the new
ideas for show formats that we're looking
for are things that we can realistically do
in a sustainable, non-suicidal way. Like,
we just don't want to die, that's all. So,
here's how you can tell us your ideas: we
made a poll. You can find the link at the
top of the description. I'm also going to
throw it in the comments, and it has some
ideas for some show formats that we
think could work, but it'll also, most
importantly, have a fill-in-the-blank
option for any idea you have, and hell,
it's also like, just a great place to
leave feedback in general. I'm really
excited about getting you all involved
in the decision-making process, because I
genuinely respect your opinions, but also
because we're going to start doing that
really regularly. Like, I don't want to
make videos about topics that you guys
don't care about. So, we're going to find
a system for you guys to just, tell us
what you care about, right f*cking now. Sound
familiar?
Actually, if any of you are like, programming
geniuses, I think it'd be really cool if
you found some way to just like, send
people to a website and then, like,
type in what they want, and it somehow
becomes like, a cool bar graph, and it's
all... data and like, numbers, and I love
that stuff, and I'm just realizing I'm
outing myself as a data nerd... cool. Just,
who cares? Get on the poll, please.
We are really eager to start rolling out
new ideas, so let's start coming up with
them. Now, before I wrap this up, there's
actually one more thing. Remember how I don't
want us to die making more content? Well
I've got a plan for that. We're going to get
Ericson some help editing, I think Kylo
is available, but his rates are also
through the roof, so we'll see, but we
also can't spread Erik too thin, either,
so we're adding some new hosts. And while
we're still talking all sorts of great
people, I want to tell you about two
specifically: Maude Garrett and Sam
Bashor. I met both of them during my
time at SourceFed Nerd (rest in peace) and
we just clicked so damn well, and guys, if
you don't know them, don't worry, we
didn't do some casting call, these two
are experts in all things nerdy, and they
are the real deal. Sam has an awesome
Podcast called only stupid answers that
you have to check out. It is so incredibly
nerdy, you're gonna love it.
And then Maude - check out her own channel,
it's called geek bomb, and you'll see
she's incredibly legit. She's the most
legit. She might even be a bigger fan of
Game of Thrones than I am. I mean,
probably not, but maybe. Maybe we should
do a show together about it, I don't know,
let us know in the poll. Now again, yes, we
are talking to other great people, too,
about joining us on camera, but I hope
you can tell how excited I am, because I
think you should be too. This wasn't some
corporation putting together a nerdy boy
band... though that is a brilliant idea.
Erik has been my best friend for over a
decade. Maude and Sam are like our
kindred spirits, except they're like,
significantly cooler than we are. I just
can't wait for you guys to get to know
them, but also maybe through them, get to
know us better, too. Like, sometimes I feel
like Erik and I maybe come off as boring
history teachers or something, and that's
not totally who we are. We're more like the
kind of cool substitute teacher who
doesn't technically have a degree in
education, but still finds some way to
justify like, playing cool movies during
class and kind of connecting it to the
lesson. Actually, the guy I'm thinking of
got fired. But anyway, I'm really excited,
I hope you are too, and if you're nervous,
I know change can be scary, and I know
more content could theoretically mean
like, a dip in quality, but do not worry. I
am seriously obsessed with quality and
doing just the best damn job that we can do. Like seriously, like, like, too obsessed. Definitely.
Okay, thank you, Ericson. Anyway, I can't
wait to hear all your ideas. Jump in the
poll. I also can't wait to make all of
the nerdy stuff for you. Also, if you
somehow ended up in this video and you
do know who Maude and Sam are, but you
don't know what the heck the channel is,
welcome sourcefed fan. Don't worry, I
think you're really going to like it
here. In fact, I'll throw up some videos that
you can check out of the kind of stuff
we make. I think it's all great. Also, stay
tuned. There's a ton of cool stuff I
didn't have time to even talk about in
this video.
So just, thank you so much, seriously, it's
good to be home.